i want to see you attack that cake  now right now the nets fans are not  cheering on michael  they are cheering on james hart we're  cheering for all of it  hardened back at the 806 mark of the  second quarter  hardin has missed 18 straight games with  the right hamstring strain  20 of the net's last 21.  such a difference maker for this team  the nets force the turnover harden oh  what a bounce for  green james harden  he's at another level oh welcome back  this is just absolutely filthy  through four players right in stride  the eyes the overhead look at that  i mean james harden makes it look too  easy  and this is from three-point territory  claxton the rebound gets rid of it  quickly for hard  i did see that movie oh you did a couple  times reese witherspoon  oh the jumper goes james harden  and the foul chef's kiss  [Applause]  oh it's getting too good here look at  this the step back  the finish blake loves it yeah we do  too bg